كانت كل الأنظار متجهة إلى إيران لمعرفة ما إذا كان
هناك أي نوع من رد الفعل الرسمي
من الحكومة الإيرانية على
الهجوم على سلمان رشدي في الولايات المتحدة
يوم الجمعة ولكن حتى الآن لم يكن هناك
رد فعل رسمي سمعناه من
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي يايا لبيد  الذي
غرد إدانة بلاده
مساء السبت وألقى باللوم أيضًا على إيران
قائلاً إن التحريض
الذي قاده ما وصفه
بالنظام المتطرف في طهران منذ عقود هو
الذي أدى إلى هذا الهجوم بالطبع ،
فقد عاد في عام 1989 إلى
إيران.  المرشد الأعلى آية الله
الخميني في ذلك الوقت الذي أصدر فتوى
هذه الفتوى الدينية الداعية
لقتل سلمان رشدي بعد
نشر كتابه
الآيات الشيطانية التي اعتبرت تجديفًا
تدنيسًا ومهينة للغاية
بالنسبة لبعض المسلمين هجومًا على
نبيهم ونبيهم  أه الدين الآن في
التسعينيات بدا أن مثل
الحكومة الإيرانية في ذلك الوقت كانت
تخفف موقفها بأنني  قد يكون
التراجع عن تلك الفتوى ولكن في السنوات
الأخيرة حتى 2017
رأينا أه المرشد الأعلى الحالي
آية الله خامنئي يقول إن هذه
الفتوى لا
تزال قائمة وأنه لم يكن لدينا أي
رد فعل حكومي رسمي لذلك  حتى الآن
رأينا ردود فعل على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وكذلك
المنشورات المحافظة المتشددة في إيران
نشرت إحدى الصحف
يوم السبت
هذا العمود الذي أشادوا فيه
بالمهاجم الذي وصفوه بأنه محارب
قائلين إنه يستحق ألف برافو
المئات من الله على يدي
هذا.  المحارب كما وصفوه
يجب أن يتم تقبيله لمهاجمته رشدي
الذي وصفوه بأنه مرتد
صحيفة أخرى أيضًا مع عنوان مقلق للغاية
الشيطان على الطريق إلى كيف كان هناك
عنوان رئيسي مع
صورة سلمان رشدي على نقالة الآن.
أيضا بعض التكهنات
والأسئلة حول ما إذا كان هذا المشتبه به في
الولايات المتحدة له أي صلات
بجماعات مدعومة من إيران أو متطرفة
مجموعات في إيران أو في أي مكان آخر في
المنطقة
كانت وسائل إعلام لبنانية تتحدث عن أن هادي
مطر
هو أيضًا مواطن لبناني
مؤهل للتصويت في البلاد ،
وهو أمر لم تتمكن CNN من
التحقق منه بشكل مستقل ،
لكن CNN تواصلت مع جماعة
حزب الله اللبنانية المدعومة من إيران.
سألهم عما إذا كانوا يعرفون أي شيء
عن المهاجم أو هذا الهجوم ، وقال أحد
المسؤولين إن
كل ما يعرفونه عن هذا الهجوم هو
ما رأوه في وسائل الإعلام أنهم
لا يعرفون شيئًا عنه وأنهم
لا يعرفون شيئًا عن هذا المشتبه به
جوماني كاراتشاي سي إن إن.